minimal and functional the Finnish way
of life finds expression in the
architecture of the capital Helsinki and
in the local design scene objects should
be practical and timeless have clean
lines and be made from robust materials
Alena Costas is a designer and has a
shop in helsinki's Design District here
design newcomers and the classics are
both represented combining the old with
the new is what this designer does - in
addition to her own collection she makes
customized pelts for a design label
archaic the design in Finland is it's
very democratic so it's it's you can say
that almost every household has some
classic design piece so you actually
grow up with it those classics are
something that I'm sure that you bear
throughout your whole life
many of these design classics have been
produced without variation for decades
designed for everyday use they combine
with one another this is especially true
of ceramics manufacturer Arabiya and
glass producer atala to celebrate the
100th anniversary of Finland's
independence they've released
collections in the typically Finnish
blue but the designs themselves remain
unchanged because they mirror the
Finnish mindset we are very near nature
we like simple things our nature is
quite clean and and poor and simple and
that maybe affects the design and also
our desire for how the design should be
so it's its functionality but still
classy a beauty with simplicity may be
the country's pioneering designer also
drew heavily on nature as early as the
1930s
Aalto laid the groundwork for the
worldwide success of Finnish design in
the 1940s and 50s
tapioca Cola revolutionized industrial
design with his icy looking glassware
kai funk did the same with his robust
timeless drinking glasses high-quality
craftsmanship and a nod to nature are
key even in the 60s when synthetic
materials became popular more than a
billion pairs of the iconic Fiskars
orange scissors have been sold to date
arrow art neo left his mark on the
swinging 60s with these round bubble
chairs these block lamps may be named
for Hari Koskinen in the 1990s building
on the success of his famous
predecessors but Finnish design isn't
only found in museums such pieces exist
in ordinary homes where they're handed
down from generation to generation it's
something children grow up with Finland
has been an independent country only for
100 years now so we need to find
something some things that were common
to everyone and design was one thing
that kind of bound whole nation together
because it was this democratic idea that
we should have good design for everybody
and a better everyday life for everybody
and design was used as a key for in the
ingredient of that so I think that's why
Finnish design has become so important
for for all things and if you say that
for the French for example it's the
bottle of wine that for example
symbolises French French people are fans
in total offense is sophistica scissors
fashion designer elena kostas sees
herself as part of this tradition she's
been selling her colorful collections
made from sheep and reindeer pelts under
the owner label since 2014
she hopes to create the fashion classics
of tomorrow I really wished and I hope
that the fashion design and the fashion
as an industry will come more
recognizable in Finland and there would
be more understanding towards the
fashion industry and the fashion design
as well because I really believe that we
have a really strong design heritage and
now it's the time for a fashion
absolutely the international customers
who flocked to her store give rise to
hope fresh design talent from Finland
adding extra color to the country's
design landscape and making sure the
next 100 years will be as successful as
the last
[Music]